here he goes seven of the eight richest
people in the world right now on or in
america right now are fierce nerds right
so you have like zuckerberg bill gates
elon musk like you have these like these
jeff bezos these types of folks but also
he says intelligence is
part you know part of the thing but
fierce nerds are not they're not winners
because they're the smartest of the
nerds in fact they're usually only
moderately intelligent uh compared to
other nerds but they are way more
competitive and impatient than than the
average nerd and this is the difference
between basically like who becomes a
professor and who becomes like a founder
or a great investor or something like
this
[Music]
all right in this episode we're talking
about sam's fight with a bunch of
nannies yeah it's that's a crazy story
that's in the beginning uh sean just had
lunch with a billionaire i had dinner
with him that they actually a few days
before super fascinating guy this this
we're actually gonna share a couple
stories that very few people get to see
i think that's the most interesting part
we also do a couple ideas we got a uh
apple-esque
apple-esque business for bathrooms and a
business around the idea of an iq test
so that's a little side hustle we got
for you so this got everything we got
frameworks we got stories we got ideas
we got it all
have you ever seen this meme of like a
black guy with a red shirt like clasping
hands with a white guy with a blue shirt
and it's like we're in this together
type of violence like the firm the firm
handshake meme yeah it's like us versus
the world race class it doesn't matter i
just had a real life incident like that
happened to me so i was out i'm in
brooklyn right now i was out in this
park in front of my house like doing
push-ups and sit-ups and just like
walking my dog just hanging out and i
see this guy i see like these four
nannies like all cicada out of like an
area where they're sitting and then i
see this like dude who's clearly
harassing them like coming after them
and
i run over there and i'm like hey what's
going on and they're like this guy just
like spit on us he's acting crazy he's
bothering us and so i give him my dog's
leash uh because i had my dog man i go
hey hold my dog for me and we i walked
over and i start talking to the guy to
get him to go away and then like it's
like oh this is clearly going to become
a fist fight and then
like five other guys who are all around
the street these guys just like
basically sit on the block all day i
don't know what they do but like one
dude was like a dominican dude another
guy was a black guy we were all and i'm
sitting there shirtless and bright green
running shorts with a fanny pack on with
airpods still in my ear and we just like
corralled these women these fours like a
jamaican nanny it was like a an asian
nanny an older white woman it looks like
and it's like we were all just like
corralling these guy or the the these
these nannies in this like circle and
we're just standing there like an
elephant garden gets hurt you know what
i'm saying and it was like
it was like the real life meme of us
coming together and at the end the crazy
person he walked away and we just look
at each other like john well done you
know just like who cares about our
backgrounds who cares what we look like
we just
we're champions of the nannies and i
just got hyped over that
first of all the fanny and the nannies
that's an amazing combo don't don't mess
with that secondly what was that analogy
like an elephant guarding it's hurt
i don't know i watch national geographic
when the lions come like the whole
community of elephants like get in a
circle and they put like the babies in
the middle and they're just saying like
you know bring it on dog and they're
just ready to fight and that's how it
felt like we were just these you're like
you know they call people like
renaissance man like you're not a
renaissance man but you do have this
strange set of influences that you watch
and you consume and you play with to
like we need like another word you're
like a redneck science man or something
like that yeah i don't know what these
things are you're like you know like
when you're swash buckling over at the
thing it's like no i don't know that
like why do you know that like you know
i like i'm watching cops but on
commercial break i'm reading ernest
hemingway you know what i'm saying like
you can't stop me
[Laughter]
how many episodes of cops have you
watched all of them jacksonville florida
is my favorite part
how do you think i know so much about
florida
what episode have i not watched
i think was the first reality tv and
that should start in the 80s
this happened this morning for you yeah
like an hour and a half ago
isn't it amazing when you when something
amazing happens in the morning the rest
of your day you got a totally different
pep in your step like i remember once i
went skydiving and i did it in the
morning and skydiving was okay it was it
was cool whatever it's over in like five
minutes right like it's like a lot of
build up that it's over in five minutes
it's like you know it's like your first
time doing it it's like you know a lot
of build up and then it's just over
and
the one thing i remember was cool it was
like
8 30 in the morning and then i like
yeah exactly i had to go on the rest of
my day
well i also made the same joke i said
your first time doing it and you said
the same joke so that's why i was like
okay oh [__] made but we can do it again
we can do it two times
well like
when you make a joke the second time and
someone's like you already said that one
like oh i i thought i thought no one
heard me
i thought maybe you didn't hear it
the um
but the rest of your day is like you
feel like a champion who could do all
things that's how i felt the day after i
scouted the morning after i skydived and
i feel like you're you're in that mood
now right you fought off the crazy guy
the crazy spitting guy with a bunch of
nannies you saved a bunch of nannies and
by proxy their babies
and so
i don't know you could kind of do
anything i could just tell you hey sam
you know
recite you know tell me the next five
companies that are going to become
trillion dollar companies and you could
just tell me
can i ask you any question right now
you're good yeah dude look i i created
the u.n of fighting off you know bad
guys it was just a bunch of us all
looking different different backgrounds
it was like it was like the beginning of
a 90s sitcom you know what i'm saying
like yeah you know the blue collar guy
the doctor you know we all came together
yeah it was it was right
it was like a cross between uh you know
golden girls and like power rangers
[Laughter]
so you you
can we talk about darmash because i have
a lot of interesting things to talk
about because i got to hang out with him
can you talk about what what you all did
yeah i think we both basically hung out
with darmesh so darmesh is the founder
of hubspot hubspot is the company that
bought your company he's a billionaire
hubspot is a he's been there for i don't
know how many years 15 plus years now in
the beginning so
kind of epic founder built a
20 billion dollar company or something
like that
and um
awesome guy really fun guy to hang out
with he listens to the pod so he's kind
of like like-minded and kind of knows
our personalities but we had never hung
out person neither had you so i think
you hung out with him at the conference
and then like a few days later i grabbed
lunch with him because he flew to san
francisco um give me your kind of
initial take give me
what you liked give me maybe something
you didn't expect and i'll do the same
so he's lovely like he's a sweetheart of
a person he's um easy to talk to like
he's incredibly like he seems
emotionally like well balanced and like
knows what he what he is and what he
isn't so a lovely hang on and then the
second thing and i mean this with love
and i mean this as a compliment he is so
odd he has done so many unique things in
his life that he like you you wouldn't
even know like he's odd in that he's
like quirky but he's also eclectic uh
incredibly eclectic so he's done so many
interesting things and when he tells you
the stories about his interesting things
you realize
oh you're like a lovely guy to be around
and you have my back and we're friends
but you are you're kind of a shark you
will you'll you win you win at
everything you do and you spot
opportunities for example he just
casually throws out these things and
he's done this to me like eight times so
i found out that when he was in his 20s
he was like you know i almost didn't
even and this reminds me of you he goes
i almost didn't even want to start tech
companies because i
um was going to become a professional
poker player i was like what he goes
yeah basically like me and my brother
we uh we were up like you know mid to
high six figures over our career our
short career of blackjack because we
learned how to play blackjack and we
learned how to do well and also we speak
a language that isn't very common i
actually don't know what language
it is but language we're in india they
don't even speak it that that much and
he's like we could talk at like the
tables and like discuss strategy and no
one would even know and uh we just would
win we i i'm up and i know how to do it
the right way and i almost became a
professional poker player and so we like
has like all these little weird things
that he'll tell stories about and i'm
like oh you're you're a killer and
you're also so unique
yeah have you ever read that paul graham
blog post called fierce nerds
no what is it i mean uh
years ago 10 years ago it's old right
um
no not that old maybe like
uh let's see where did he publish this
the public says 2021 one no no no no no
it's an amazing post i'm gonna read you
a couple pieces of it but it is
it's one of those like program i think
is somebody said this earlier they go uh
uh what's the guy andrew tate they saw
some tweet that was really funny was
paul graham was my andrew tate like
growing up
like so funny so it's such a funny it's
such a deep cut joke but if you get it
you're like it just hits the spot
so um all right so he wrote this post
and he goes most people think of nerds
as quiet you know sort of like different
people right just sort of like uh you
know passive
and
in most social situations they are
they're they're quiet and you know
they're not the star quarterback in the
middle of the gym right they're um
they're kind of a fish out of water in a
bunch of different things
he goes
um but this is an illusion because when
on that only happens when non-nerds
observe them because they're observing
them in non-nerdy situations so you see
a nerd at prom you just see them as a
quiet sort of passive nerd there's no
alpha in them
and he goes but in fact some nerds are
quite fierce
fierce nerds are a small but interesting
group they are extremely competitive
more competitive i would say than
competitive non-nerds because the
competition is more personal to them
partly because they're not emotionally
mature
and they distance themselves from it
but also because there's less randomness
in the types of competition that they
engage in therefore they're justified in
making it more personal so this is like
fierce nerds who get really into chess
or a game that is less luck-based more
skill-based uh this often happens with
gaming or programming competitions or
math competitions or spelling bees
way less about luck way more about skill
darmesh told me a story he was like when
i was in grade school or high school i
uh like i got in trouble because i just
like didn't go to school or like
something like that and i was like wow
he goes well i had never seen a ping
pong table and they had one of those in
the dorm and i right when i saw it i
decided i'm going to be the best at this
and so i dedicated my high school years
to being the best ping-pong player uh
but sorry go ahead really yes that's
amazing uh i love how you get these gems
out of people like what question do you
ask that gets that answer
i uh like i'll just say like like wow
you're like really unique like how are
you so why are you so different no no
how did you really say it wow you're so
freaking weird man yeah i was like did
you do stuff your whole life i was like
you're a weirdo i'm like i'm kind of
i'll say like i'm kind of a weirdo too
but you're like extreme weird like what
were you like in high school
yeah yeah yeah that's that's that's the
sam park question i i needed to get that
out of you then those are great because
i'll be honest with you i had lunch with
him and super nice by the way keep
reading your article
okay here we go fair enough uh so he go
so he goes on to talk about it he's like
here's some other things about about
fierce nerds one they're
independent-minded they're willing to
basically stand on what they believe
even though it is socially awkward
you know in school this becomes kind of
a liability for them but as soon as they
graduate they go into kind of the
professional world it becomes an extreme
asset for them
um
they're also impatient they're annoyed
by rules rather than being just like you
know unaware of them or passively
following them and he goes i'm not
because i'm not sure why fierce nerds
are impatient but they most of them seem
to be you'll notice at first in
conversation they tend to interrupt you
at first it's merely annoying but it's
but the more promising fierce nerds it's
connected to a deeper impatience about
solving the problem they have this
competitiveness and impatience right so
those are two of the like
characteristics
and um
he goes when you combine these qualities
in sufficient quantity the result is
quite formidable
and then he gives some examples and he
goes that's a beautiful sentence by the
way one more part if you combine these
in sufficient
yeah that's a really good sentence
yeah
here he goes seven of the eight richest
people in the world right now on or in
america right now are fierce nerds right
so you have like zuckerberg bill gates
elon musk like you have these like these
jeff bezos these types of folks
um
he goes the bad news he goes he goes
indeed he basically but also he says
intelligence is par you know part of the
thing but fierce nerds are not
they're not winners because they're the
smartest of the nerds in fact they're
usually only moderately intelligent uh
compared to other nerds but they are way
more competitive and impatient than than
the average nerd and this is the
difference between basically like who
becomes a professor and who becomes like
a founder or a great investor or
something like this
and so uh he goes he goes
he goes the idea of a fierce nerd is not
a common one so a lot of you might be
reading this and might realize hmm
that's me and he goes and now and i love
this writing he goes and it is to you
young fierce nerd that i now turn and he
goes and he starts talking directly to
the fierceness he goes i got good good
news and bad news the good news is your
fears is going to help you solve
difficult problems so you know
scientific technical problems blah blah
blah you can get rich in business
um
in greed it is great for you know
survival to be a fierce dirt he goes the
bad news is that if not exercise your
fierceness will turn into bitterness and
you'll become an intellectual playground
bully a grumpy sis admin the forum troll
the hater and the shooter down of new
ideas
he goes how do you avoid this fate and
by the way he created hacker news so i
think he runs into a lot of fierce nerds
on hacker news he goes how do you avoid
this fate work on ambitious projects
because if you succeed it brings you the
kind of satisfaction that will
neutralize your bitterness
you don't have to succeed to feel this
merely working on hard projects gives
most fierce nerds a sense of
satisfaction
um and it and it and even if you don't
succeed it'll keep you busy so you're
not so bitter
i thought this is an amazing blog post
like what it is you you you
i said literally i read this i sent it
to emmett at twitch i was like hey it's
you like this is you this is what i
would describe you as like a fierce nerd
and he went through y combinator so you
know he's like you know the archetype
for it so you just pulled this up by the
way without having any preparation and
you did a really good job by the way of
like reading that i was like enthralled
uh but dude paul graham very hard by the
way because i read this i know a year
ago
and i'm like skimming it trying to cut
the boring parts and also remember what
the hell was this article about that was
actually quite difficult i know you did
a really good job i was like tell me
more tell me more um
paul graham's a great writer uh i lo i'm
gonna go back and reread that okay and i
interrupted you
to i interrupted the interruption so you
met with darmesh and you said to be
honest he was a nice guy i forget what
you said so so he's a fierce nerd that's
the first thing and i think you pulled
out some good stories the ping pong
story the poker story this is classic
fierce nerd hallmarks right all green
flags uh going towards that the second
part was
super nice guy and our lunch is totally
fine
but
there is a certain uh
it's he's this type of person actually
there's a bunch of people like this i
might be like this where you're almost
better to talk to online it's like
you've spent more time talking to people
online that your online social skill
is better than your in-person social
skill i felt this myself because right i
left the house for the first time in
many you know many days to go do a
social hangout like
he even texted he was like you know
totally understand by the way if you
don't want to come i'm like you i don't
like to leave the house and you know i'm
protective of my time and i was like no
no i want to do this i'll i'll drive an
hour let's do this um
i felt rusty and i could feel almost
that he was a little rusty or like but
differently not rusty necessarily but
his main
comfort zone right his pocket his
cockpit as a pilot
is
sitting at his desk in front of a
computer and i know a bunch of people
like this i have this guy we used to
work with jake if you met him he's as
quiet as mouse in slack he's like the
class clown and i was like what who is
this guy that's you dude you're like the
most soft-spoken like you know that foot
pedal on a piano that makes all the keys
like muted he's like that for real life
like somebody needs to like take the
foot off the foot pedal for him and but
then you get him in slack and the guy's
like you know the number one troll
willing to cut the edgy jokes and i was
like i can't believe this is the same
guy and it's like he was 21 years old he
basically grew up in malaysia his only
like english social interactions were
online in like in chat rooms games
discord that sort of thing and so you
know that's just his persona and i've
met so many people that are like this
that i've now come to realize it's not
something weird about them it's actually
a completely normal thing
and it's better to just figure out
what's you where are you the most you
is it through text messaging is it on
phone calls is it through written emails
is it in person is it like long form in
person what is the version of you that's
the most you uh like what would you say
it is for you
um
writing like long form writing um i
think that's what i prefer like these
podcasts like i usually have to lay down
for like 30 minutes because i'm like i'm
like dead
after them so no i mean i'm okay with
this but like writing i prefer but
listen to this so i think darm mesh
would actually grow you like to elevate
your legs to get the blood back to your
brain yeah it's like i'm so tired i
passed out what happened uh
uh darmesh um i would probably agree
with you i would imagine and but so
listen to this so
they they asked you and me to like show
up so basically i was supposed to speak
at this event and they're like hey uh
one of the main people had to cancel
because something happened can you show
up like in 12 hours the next morning and
come and speak in front of 10 000 people
and i was like i mean i guess i could
just like show up and riff in front of
10 000 people but i don't prefer that
just darmesh when i like do a thing and
they're like no he hates public speaking
i'm like just let me ask him he'll do it
so he ended up doing it but backstage i
asked him about that
and he's like yeah i don't i hate public
speaking i'm not good at it and i go
well you just did a keynote earlier
today why'd you do that and he goes i'll
tell you why basically for the six
months or five months or whatever it was
leading up to this event i had this
process where i read a bunch of comedy
books and i realized that the laugh per
minute was the most important thing for
a talk and so what i did was i got first
i made a presentation i got and i
created a zoom call and i got 10 hubspot
employees to do it and i recorded the
whole thing then i got 20 to come and
then 50 to come and then 100 to come and
what i did was i adapted each time and i
built this python i built this python
script that analyzed the audio of the
call to figure out what my laugh per
minute was and then each time i adapted
it to get more laughs per minute so for
example and he knew the exact numbers he
goes i had 96 slides on this
presentation and i had to click next 120
times and i know on which laugh and on
which word to hit next because i
practiced it so much because i'm
optimizing for lap my he kept going at
the the lpm wow
and uh
what the hell this is amazing it's
amazing these types of stories it's
amazing and he like he and i went back
and watched his talk and he goes in fact
so here's like another like side tangent
have you ever been to a big conference
have you noticed whether it's ted talk
or even steve jobs all the big
conferences that have more than a
thousand people they all use the same
slide clicker have you ever seen that
clicker it only has two buttons a red
which means a back and a right and a and
a green which means next so here's the
secret that clicker it doesn't actually
change the slide it goes to a light like
a light that says red or green and
there's someone on the other end of the
slide hitting left or right did you know
that
no
yeah so that's like
so it's so stupid because they do it
because like the presenters or the
organizers will be like well in case you
could screw up someone's here and we'll
do a better job but it's not automated
like it this is how it works at all big
conferences so it's like this clicker or
whatever we have to do a talk on it
actually they have they've completely
monopolized it so every single big
conference has this and and i told him
that he goes dude
trust me i know i've gotten in fights
with these people for eight years
because i built a device and a program
to make it so that clicker could
actually work directly with the computer
because in order to optimize my lpm i
need the click to happen faster that a
human bead can see the light and click
next because that's how i've set it up
and every once in a while there'll be a
slight delay which decreases my lpm and
so
this is how this guy looks at everything
and he told me about his lpm like you
think about your t levels
he just like spends months optimizing
his lpm
and this is just like when i hear
stories like this i think hey you're
unstoppable like
this is why you're successful and b i
love you like i i i just you're my hero
and
everything you're about i'm into now and
i just i love it man i love when these
people are so extreme about [__] it's
awesome
that's amazing ah that is amazing what
an amazing story you've made my day um
that that is really incredible i i can't
even uh
yeah i can't even kind of wrap my head
around the level of nerdery it takes
to go that deep on something like you
know
um
i feel like i live my life in this like
80 20 way where like
good enough is as good as it gets and
like i just kind of good enough is as
good as it gets for like almost
everything in my life
very rarely do i try to like take
something to that like
nth degree that in that olympic level of
obsession
and part of me is very jealous of people
who do that um like we another fierce
nerd we had was this guy quinn who used
to work at um at our company
and quinn same thing most soft-spoken
guy you might have met him he had the
big crazy yeah i know
uh
most soft-spoken guy gentle like if
there was a fly that landed on his wrist
he'd be like it's your wrist now fly
right like this
never said a bad word about anybody
and um
he was like a fierce nerd like we we
started playing like these little word
games in the office and i was like oh
quinn you should play like this uh like
you know like imagine like wordle but
like 10 years ago and he's like
oh i could see him like getting like
visibly stressed about it i was like
whoa like no problem man what's wrong
like you you don't want to play
he goes no but if i play then i'm just
going to get super obsessed with it like
i'm just going to take it too far and i
was like what do you mean he's like
he's like yeah i just have to be careful
with games like this i just get like
really into it i just have to win
and i was like you like what do you mean
like you're this ruthless competitor get
out of here he goes did i ever show you
the girlfriend thing and i was like
what's the girlfriend thing and he goes
you know that game that's like that word
scramble game uh like basically it's a
bunch of letters nine letters on a grid
you're trying to like create as many
words as you can just like dragging your
finger across the line
he's like yeah my girlfriend beat me in
that game once
and then i went to google's headquarters
and i programmed the artificial robot
arm to just make as many swipes as
possible in like every like per second
and uh like i just crushed her and i'm
like i'm the world record holder now of
this game like you basically
like programmed the robotic arm he added
a little like nerf gun tip to it so it'd
be soft like a it could just scrape
against the screen
and then he just programmed it to move
in every direction the optimal path to
like create as many words as it can in
like you know a minute and it's like his
time is like unbelievably higher than
everybody else and his girlfriend's like
well this game's not fun anymore like i
don't understand what's happened like
what happened here and he's like
i happened
dude let me tell you one more last uh
darmesh story so
he owns
like uh
he has an eight-figure domain portfolio
so like
random things like he owns cambridge.com
which he like just lets the government
use
um you know how i uh i have this
copywriting thing i i was using try copy
that and he goes hey for your birthday i
bought you copythat.com and i was like
what that's like he's like try not being
a [__]
[Laughter]
thanks dad
dude that's hilarious so he owns all
these domain names and i was like what
okay well you have this world thing and
you have all these domains any projects
that interest you he goes i've been
thinking really a lot about creating a
venn diagram community i was like what
what are you crazy he goes well i own
venndiagram.com
and i love communities and i'm into math
and i think there's a lot of other
people who are also obsessed with venn
diagrams i think i'm going to build a
really cool community for venn diagrams
and uh i don't know because you're gonna
see them having like a tattoo on their
arm of just a van there's a bunch of
banners yeah uh we're all just better
just getting in the room
i've been overlapped everywhere
i don't know like what it's like there's
a circle there's a circle you see how
this circle i have what are they gonna
just talk about it all the time i mean i
i don't understand like what the
like you know this circle is bigger this
one's smaller i i don't know
man you can't you can't help it
but that's what he's going to build is a
venn diagram community because he owns
venndiagram.com can can i tell you five
random domains that i own uh actually
i'll tell you six random domains that i
own i want you i'm gonna say let's play
a little game i'm gonna say a domain
and you're gonna just pitch me a
business off off the domain off top of
your head all right
okay
all right you froze alright there you go
um okay number one
excel monkeys.com a domain i own excel
monkeys.com what does it do
all right excel monkeys.com that's where
you buy
smart chimpanzees
that's your best idea with excel monkeys
you buy smart monkeys
yeah because they accept monkey's so
smart they could use excel
excel monkeys it would be um that would
be the name of a tax service
yeah it could be a tax service it could
also be like selling amazing excel
templates for stuff it's like oh you
need like a cash flow statement here's a
great one you need like a p l here's a
great excel wait did you buy excel
monkeys because that's what i used to
call people
did you do that
yeah whenever i meet these finance nerds
in reality i was always jealous of them
because they were making more money than
me like my friends and i'd be like dude
you're just an excel monkey man like
they're just all you do is play and
excel you don't do anything you don't
create real value like me like you know
i write a newsletter
dude i i have so many phrases like that
like um bakers who are always making
powerpoints i'm like ah freaking slide
jockey over here i don't know what it
was i don't even know why but i'm like i
want it to be derogatory or like uh the
best one of all of them is the finance
department that like watches the budget
you have to get your expenses it's like
uh yeah i gotta go talk to the bean
counters i like heard some guy say this
he was like in his 60s and i think it's
a common phrase but i was like oh that
was like a racial slur as far as i was
concerned i was like wow calling someone
a bean counter that sounds i like that
you were allowed to say that in the
office that's incredible i'm gonna use
that when i was uh you know younger and
i was jealous of all these bankers
they'd be like oh you know i work in
banking like oh no [__] which branch
you know like uh i go to the one in
columbia is that where you are
you ever been robbed has ever come in
with a ski basket
okay excel monkeys that's a uh uh
that's a it's a website for tax experts
what's the next one all right next one
skillbad.com
i own
skillbad.com bad
i don't know sounded good it's too easy
to spell easy to say words put together
like you're bad at something i don't
know
but it's ironic
what what would you
what like what would that be
what were you thinking it's like
skillshare bro it's so that's that's a
layup right there it's like skillshare
it's uh you're bad at a skill
come to skill bad
we help you go from being bad at
something to being good at something
that's stupid that is really stupid
i can't find this client info have you
heard of hubspot hubspot is a crm
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
aligned no out of sync spreadsheets or
dueling databases hubspot grow better
[Music]
i got um
it's tummy time.com it's tummy time baby
it's tummy tuck what is it what are we
doing at tummy time
just uh
what do you do on tummy time is that
when the what's the baby do just sit
there and watch tv
what's tummy time i don't even know
dude
it helps them like uh you know like
develop their core strength or their
neck strength to like look up so they
don't just be face down but they don't
necessarily watch tv but yeah you could
do that obviously you're gonna be
selling baby aerobics classes
i don't know i'm sure you'd go for like
a six minute abs thing it's tummy time
baby
i don't even know what that is
you know i'm not i don't i'm not there
yet
and what are the last two we're gonna
have to work on your improv skills
you've been working on comedy but not
improv i feel like uh i feel like the on
the spot throw something at you i'm
gonna practice i'm gonna keep doing this
segment until you're dude i'm i'm still
at the yes and part of the book
what's the one thing everyone knows
about improv
yes i am it's like the number one tell
that you've never done it
you say you know an improv
you know an improv we have this thing
called yes and
it means don't disagree with me in this
meeting instead say yes and then make my
idea better because it's bad right now
have you ever gone out to dinner with a
bunch of improv people
dude i did improv for like you know
eight weeks of my life dude i've gone
out to dinner what time i wanted nothing
more obnoxious than a bunch of people
i'd rather be with the vendors yes i'd
rather be with the venn diagram dorks
and a bunch of improvers
yuck they go it goes like in in in like
places i don't want to be number two on
top of that list is improvers number one
is people who are part of acapella
groups oh my god i was about to say the
same thing acapella where they're just
like hey
yeah yeah
yeah
[Music]
oh god here we go
don't sing to me in the on the
mcdonald's slide that you want a number
one bruh just tell me your big back with
no with no audience
you know what makes any situation worse
singing
i cannot stand the acapella people i
didn't realize that was a thing where i
grew up in missouri if you were part of
the acapella people would make fun of
you but then i started meeting people on
the east coast like these people who go
to harvard and cornell and [__] and they
would brag about being part of like so
serious about it i'd be like
dude why are you telling people that
what are you doing like don't be talking
about doesn't bob like you don't talk
about that and they're like why it's
awesome i was always amazed at acapella
people
dude on duke's campus like who gets laid
number one basketball players number two
acapella and i was like what the hell
what's going on it was crazy
yeah i have these like dating rules by
the way uh never date anybody who's into
who's in a what is it called equestrian
somebody who likes to ride horses never
date a horseback rider
never date a dancer
uh never date an acapella person
uh those are my three those are the
three like you just never want to do it
why
they're obsessed with something that's
by all accounts useless number two they
all of their hobbies are extremely
either expensive or time consuming away
from you number number three
half of those hobbies basically are like
really intimate with other people that
are not you they're just going to be
doing salsa with some like you know
some suave guy from latin america who
doesn't speak english but is touching
all over your person you don't want to
do that right so these hobbies and the
same and then also you can't do the
thing so oh you're at a wedding great
isn't it awesome you date a dancer no
it's not awesome you turn into a pole
while they are doing like actual dancing
or oh you date a singer great why don't
you just sit there and nod and like tap
your foot while they who they actually
know how to sing so it's like
do together
i never dance at weddings i just act
like i have to go to the bathroom every
song i freaking hate it
i hate what it dances i watch
like i find two bathrooms on opposite
poles
i just make laps between them dude i
don't ever dance like i i watched a ufc
fight the toilet the other day like i
had a wedding i don't i
didn't
saturday nights i watched ufc at like
three weddings already
yeah i hate going to weddings and going
to the dance floor i just tell sarah
like don't even ask me and they're like
well it's fine i'm like uh no this is
the worst i don't want to do this i
don't know what to do i don't like it it
just it ain't for me
there's a great little crystalia clip on
youtube about it if you see it he goes
there's no bigger dick move than
inviting your friend to your wedding
because if you're doing an out-of-state
wedding and you invite me
like you know what you just did to me
you know what you just did you cost me
money time i don't want to be at a
wedding and i thought it was like very
very true um all right new uh new
segment so
or a new idea
so
i got two ideas for you would you like
to hear about i'll give you options
would you like to hear about
the next apple
or would you like to hear about
um
the next
the next little side hustle that i think
could kind of work
the next app or the next side hustle
that might kind of work well the second
one
all right
just as i expected
um
do you know your iq
no of course not
ben do you know your iq of course he
does
i i've done only unofficial iq tests
what does that mean yeah
like a banner ad on a website
yeah so there's some online that's
supposed to be better than others but
basically in order to get your actual iq
it's supposed to be like proctored and
they have someone administer it but you
can go take tests online i took one of
the better ones um
but it's still not like a totally
accurate iq okay i had one of the better
arby's the other day
[Laughter]
so it's kind of like that yeah what did
you get yeah what's your iq it said 132.
oh this genius level right
no
no but it's it's it's smart but not
genius
so um
i think you could create a ddc iq brand
uh so i think you could basically say
the same playbook that everybody's using
for d2c brands right uh
we were just joking about banner ads but
yes banner ads
facebook ads taboola ads everywhere i
think you could optimize a funnel that
basically buys clicks for less than a
dollar
and then converts
you know
let's call it uh i don't know whatever
ten percent of people uh you need to
convert ten percent of people to pay you
the
25 bucks that it's going to take or the
you know maybe it's the maybe it's maybe
it's 99 bucks or something like that you
have to figure out some version of the
economics that's going to make sense to
make this the math work on the cac
versus the the value but
i feel like somebody could create a
funnel that will get you in why do i
think that this will work it's not
really economics driven it's just
work backwards from what's an ad that i
think would work and i think an ad
that's like only geniuses can solve this
puzzle
um like i i don't know if you've seen
these ads on tick tock that are like
people say this puzzle is impossible or
this number game is impossible you can't
draw a line through these four things
without lifting your finger and you're
like i bet i can do that that looks
doable and you like click it and then
now it tells you to download some game
but instead of a game i think it could
be basically like an iq game and i think
you can basically make a monthly
subscription that's like these are iq
games or iq tests to get your score um
for either you or maybe maybe it's
maybe we're going after the baby
einsteins maybe it's for your kids
because i think people want to know if
their kid's a genius more than as an
adult it's less less important and so i
think somebody could build a d2c iq test
that like
i don't know exactly how well it'll do
but would it surprise you if i told you
dude i met this guy and he runs this
like facebook funnel that basically
takes you down an iq test and then you
pay for your results and uh and like
half the people forget to cancel their
subscription
um
and the guy makes you know 50 50 000 a
month or the guy makes a hundred
thousand a month doing this would you be
shocked if i told you that no in fact i
think you could build a company that
could actually make nine figures like
100 million plus and here's why um i
think i've told you about this but
you have you ever heard of gallup you've
definitely heard of gallup like they
they're cited in service
yeah they're surveys well they own this
company uh called clifton strengths have
you heard of clifton shrinks i i think
clifton shrinks we've talked about this
way we talked about it way back in the
day but we should do it again because
the pod was way smaller back then but
yeah i've done this test the strength
finder test i don't have all my research
so i'm going off memory but basically
strengths finders i think it was a test
and then a book or a book than a test
something like that it's a book that has
a link to the test inside so basically
the book is like you don't even need to
read the book the book just has like a
code so let's go to this website type in
this thing
now you take the test and then it gives
you at the end like your six or seven
strengths it's like oh you're a futurist
this is like
literally tarot card reading to me like
it's like you're a futurist you're a
determined leader you're
you know problem solver or whatever i
don't know what they are but like i took
the test and i was like oh they just
gave me seven like generically positive
words
like
oh for sure i could identify with some
of these and like great what does this
do
it's a horoscope but basically gallup
the company gallup is a survey business
they own strengths finders and gallup is
privately owned but if i remember
correctly four years ago maybe it's two
years ago when i did research on them i
think they're north of a billion dollars
in revenue and clifton strengthsfinder i
think what it is is um so they charge
like 40 to 50 bucks for one of these
simple things and but then they do like
more heavy-duty consulting where they'll
like put your whole company through it
and
during my research i'm pretty sure that
that test was making hundreds of
millions of dollars a year in revenue
because they have thousands of employees
in like i don't know where they're based
like minnesota or like something they're
just like one of these i guess they're
the main thing gallup is based in dc but
it's one of these companies that you
like totally forget about that exists
and you just don't even think about it
but if you look at the traffic of their
website and you look at some of the
numbers based off of news articles it's
like a pretty
wildly huge company
right is it private or is it public it's
uh it's private it might have been
public at one point but it's like they
have on wikipedia it says they've got 50
offices and i know they have thousands
and thousands of employees and it's
privately owned by uh i think still just
the the family
wow uh yeah that's amazing yeah so i
think you could do like the this is like
the enterprise personality test that's
what i call it uh you could do the
personality tests you could do the love
language uh test you could do iq
i think you could do a d2c funnel that
would work with these things um so i
don't know i'm kind of interested in
this i think this is like if you're a
good internet marketer like actually not
good i think you kind of need to be an
amazing internet marketer yeah if you're
amazing internet marketer the world is
your oyster but like one fun one that i
think somebody could spin up would be um
these like sort of uh
take a test get a score type things
whether it's personality or it's iq okay
so that's that's that one
now let me tell you my apple idea
all right
i'm taking a shower today
and that's nice
you're welcome
the
my one of my favorite feelings of the
day i'll give you a list of my favorite
feelings most people don't have this
list but i gotta i got a list of
favorite feelings throughout the day in
my top five two of them
maybe three come in the bathroom
showers
wash my hands
taking a poop love all three of them
[Laughter]
my trainer says this thing by the way do
you do it in that order
that'd be you'd be a freak if you did it
in that order
[Laughter]
it's not a routine in that order
we go the other way right there's a
there's a method
by the way my trainer has this thing he
says which is like uh he's like yeah of
all my clients he's like the number one
thing people actually like struggle with
is like stress and he goes what's the
opposite of stress and it's like i don't
know relief he's like yeah belief
satisfaction he goes he goes think about
how many things a day stress you out i
was like oh that's a lot there's a bunch
of things that can stress somebody out
he goes think about how many things give
you relief in a day he goes i was like
kind of struggling to think of anything
he's like
he's like people usually have relief
once a day
it's right when they're pooping and he's
like that's the only time they
experience this emotion that's why
they're bad at it they don't practice
that emotion very much and i was like
wow that's that's interesting so
anyways back to my story
i love having clean hands after washing
my hands i love taking a shower and i
love the relief all right great so
but when i'm in those situations right
now if i go to my shower
nothing that's special
i i don't know i got standard shower
head
shampoo body wash got a loofah in there
because you know my wife hooks me up you
know so this is this is like that's what
i'm working with and for something that
i do every day
something that's like you know kind of a
important part of my day why
i i think somebody could make an apple
for the bathroom and what what is the
company that's apple for the bathroom
gonna do so i don't know have you ever
tried to like hack your shower
experience to make it more awesome it's
really really trying to do things
i bought i was really interested in like
different shower heads and i remember
researching them on wire cutter and i
bought the fanciest one and then i it
wasn't even that fancy but the best one
and i remember like it took forever to
call handyman to install it it was i was
gonna say where did you fall fall into
the trap installing it right it's always
the install that's like you know who's
going to do that
versus like a nest a nest was like easy
i did that
and same thing with toilets it's like
you we've probably all heard that
there's these japanese toilets that are
amazing that will like you know give you
a butt massage or whatever you know
they're they're like incredible toilets
but who's going to rip out their toilet
and replace it with this fancy one
that's a that's a big big overhaul and
washing your hands nobody even touches
the mirror nobody touches like there's
so i think you could build a product
that simply says i'm going to give
people
relaxation and relief i'm going to give
them
motivation and inspiration
through products just for the bathroom
and you could just nerd out about how to
make the bathroom experience amazing
like i bought these little eucalyptus
like pods that you put in the shower and
basically when hot water hits the the
pod it like releases like this
eucalyptus like kind of like aroma
awesome right like the the thing itself
is kind of janky like it's not the best
product like uh you know in between it
gets all soggy it's not great it's like
it's only good the first time
but the concept is amazing and it's like
why isn't there just a better diffuser
that's gonna add this like eucalyptus
steam into my shower while i'm doing
this why isn't there an add-on
attachment that doesn't require me to
replace my shower head but just makes
the shower head better
um why isn't there something that's on
my mirror that is motivational and
inspirational that's like that looks
nice why isn't there a product that's
like washing your hands but it's not
washing your hands it's like some
heat uv [__] i don't know something
that's gonna like make my hands feel
clean and toasty um why isn't there uh
eight sleep for the toilet that's a
device that sits inside the toilet and
measures your pee in your poo it tells
you when you need to go see a doctor or
you know the quality of your hydration
or whatever else
i think that somebody should build a
company i want some
somebody who is like
that venn diagram between quantified
self they like they want to like
optimize their you know the rob deer
dick i am human optimization they're
that guy but they're also a hardware
nerd and somebody who has that overlap i
just wish that they would create apple
for the bathroom so it's i think it's
something i wish somebody made because i
would buy
hundreds of dollars worth of products
from a brand that could actually do that
well what do you think of this idea dude
so uh i i haven't researched a ton of
this but um there's two interesting
players in this space right now so
interestingly both of them have come
from like
tier one vc back businesses that they
previously started in traditional like
cool kid
area so the first one i think is it
called revolution bathrooms
uh made revolution made revolution
made renovation i believe it started by
i think it's roger dickey i think his
name is his company was called gigster
successful tech guy who started like
businesses i think they have sold for
hundreds of millions of dollars and he
like up and quit like this one like
company that he had gigser that was
killing it and he's like i'm going to
get into the bathroom business and so a
little bit different than what you're
talking about but interesting but
another one that's actually really cool
have you heard of block renovation
they do the same thing right
ish yeah i believe they do the same
thing but basically the coolest thing
about this is if you go to the website
it looks slick and cool and everything
and it almost fits your venn diagram
once because the guy who started it his
name is luke sherwin he's the former
founder of casper
uh so he like took casper public and
left and then he started this thing for
bathrooms and i think at this point i
think they've brought in
90 million in funding or 50 million in
funding i forget but it's like close to
100 million and i think it's like doing
really really well
yeah both of these are basically how do
you renovate your bathroom
so that you get a like super nice
looking bathroom or in their case
kitchen also
um like just like pick from the menu
it's like here's you know
here's five amazing bathroom designs
pick one and then we have people that
can install that bathroom in your
bathroom turn key versus today the way
you do a renovation is like all right
what do you guys think of for tile it's
like i don't know i never thought about
tile uh what are the options and how
much does each one of these cost and
like okay then what about sinks and you
just sort of have to piecemeal it
whereas this was like a turnkey bathroom
in a box which is a great idea this was
one of the first ideas we brought up on
on this show by the way was i saw this
ad and i was like this made renovation
idea is amazing and i should have just
invested in it because back then it was
like in a seed stage like it was very
early and um yeah both these have done
really well
have you ever tried to buy a bidet so
like what you can do is buy these like
bidet uh covers where basically it's
like this
like it's basically just a sophisticated
toilet seat and dude they are so janky
like you have like an electric right
there never installed it and in fact
broke my toilet trying to install it
dude they're so janky and you have like
a cord going from like where your like
electric razor goes and you're like what
the [__] why is this cord like going
like across the room like running from
the kitchen into my bathroom yeah and
then you've got this like stupid hose
that goes up to the top of the toilet it
just looks like like a science
experiment like it's duct taped together
it sucks right but i've always wanted
one you know like whenever you know you
use one yeah i want a real bidet yeah
that's sick that's dope so yeah i'm on
board i i think this is uh
the next apple that's ambitious maybe
the next company that gets bought by
apple i didn't say it's the next apple i
said it's apple for the bathrooms
meaning it's a company that just cares
about the design the simplicity of use
and um just making a really high quality
product and people are willing to pay a
premium way more than you think they're
willing to pay three times more
if you could actually pull that level of
quality off and i think that you have
this place where people go all the time
you have the shower you have toilet you
have a sink you have a mirror if these
things to work with and then you have
all the accessories oh maybe this scale
that i have in my bathroom is like i
don't know it's just like some random
weight scale maybe there's like a really
good version of that that can go with it
you could just cross sell into all these
different categories but you just say
we're gonna own the bathroom we're gonna
make the goddamn best products ever for
the bathroom and i think if somebody
just simply took that idea
and then just decided to execute on that
for like 10 years you could have a
billion dollar company in the same way
that like you know the nest thermostat
was able to sell for a billion dollars
right like i think if you can if you can
actually pull off this thing that's in
every home and then with a bathroom you
got like three or four in every home so
it's like you have this like um this
thing that today everybody kind of
ignores and just treats in this uh sort
of like it's an afterthought type of way
no i think that's dope i'm in you want
to do one more or what uh i want to talk
about one other concept which is
uh actually do you have do you have one
we could do one of yours if you want no
if you want to do it
all right no
i gave a talk at hustle con
with this phrase and
in my mind i was like oh yeah we've
already talked about that but i'm like
wait a minute no that was just that
hustle con i don't know there's like a
couple hundred people in the room at my
breakout talk uh so most people have not
heard this concept the the one on
selling a company it was the one on how
to sell your company and in general it's
really about like you know
how to do a part of business that you
don't do often and maybe you don't have
the reps in so like most people who
become like business owners ceos you're
great at product you may be great at
marketing you might be good at finance
and making money but what you're not
good at is stuff that you only do once
in a while like fundraising or um m a or
um
you know things like that sort of like
these large one-off transactions that
are very important
very expensive you don't want to get
them wrong but you also don't have reps
doing it and um and the other side like
when you're fundraising the investor
they talk to hundreds of people like you
every month
they're getting tons of reps so it's a
very asymmetric
skill set you don't really know how to
negotiate like them you don't know what
clauses are standard and what are not
standard um so you don't have that same
level of reps that the other party has
same thing with m a you're going to
talking to somebody who does m a for a
living and um and they've done hundreds
of deals and you don't know the first
thing about the first thing
and so here's the solution that most
people have right like if you're really
big you can afford a banker like uh did
you guys use a banker i don't think so
when you when you sold right you may
have i had advisors but
i had hired one and then i disliked them
so i fired them so i ended up being the
banker
right and same thing when we sold i was
the banker but i had a a i talked to a
banker who could kind of give me some
free advice from time to time
i had a really good lawyer that was like
a huge thing although i do see the value
in a banker i do think that a good
banker
totally is worth a fee a good lawyer is
100 needed right this guy dick filipina
he he he was amazing actually he was a
banker that helped me but we were too
small for like his normal deals right he
does 100 million plus deals and we were
way under that so um so basically i was
like okay well i don't have i could
maybe do a boutique banker but again
which one i don't know who's good who's
not uh you said you had a great lawyer
cool i got a lawyer is my lord great are
they okay are they good like how am i
supposed to assess this and by the time
you you figure out if your lawyer was
good or not in a transaction it's too
late it's too late
it's done same thing with tax strategy
or negotiation all these different
components
and so i talked about like
um doing this process is like a very
fundraising is usually like an intense
sprint uh m a is like an intense sprint
it's this couple month process that you
work on really hard it becomes your main
focus at the end of the day you're
trying to like get to this amazing end
point i was like i made the comparison i
was like it's like birthing a baby and
you go through this labor process and
then by the end you like you have the
thing you wanted at the end
and so
just like when you're having a baby you
you might have a doula a doula somebody
that kind of like they're not your
doctor right this the doctor would be
like your lawyer right uh they're not
your nurse they should be like maybe
you're your cpa
um
they're just somebody who's there to
coach you guide you and they've been
they've seen the births of hundreds of
babies whereas this might be your first
and i talked about you need a deal doula
i was like if you're going to do a deal
if you're going to do a transaction
you're going to do a fundraising you
need a deal
it's different than a mentor a mentor is
this like general thing in life that's
like going to be your kind of like your
you know the better version of your dad
and a deal doula is specific it's for
this period of time it's around one
specific problem or process that you're
going through and i talked about how
when i when i sold my last company
i had these five deal doulas i started
with and eventually it ended up being
these two that i was working with the
most but like i talked about
and uh who else yeah uh there was this
guy flawed who i talked to who gave me
great advice like he told me one thing
like each one of them told me like one
thing that was really important so that
guy dick was one of them uh but like for
example foreign told me he's like you
need to he's like oh cool i was like so
excited i was like look we got this like
these guys are interested they're about
to give us a term sheet tomorrow and he
was like you know just sort of chuckling
and he's like sure i was like oh you
don't think they'll do it he's like
it'll happen it's just
every timeline you think of is wrong
everything they say is gonna fall
through and then come back and then half
full through again he's like this is the
normal m a process so you might have an
outlier where it just all goes smoothly
but like if you're gonna have a normal m
a process you should expect these bumps
and bruises and it's like you know going
through these contractions basically
these like painful ups and downs during
the process he also said he's like you
need to turn your company into a giant
buy button i was like what do you mean
he's like you know when you go to amazon
it's like one click checkout he's like
you think because these guys are giving
your term sheet you're at the end so
this is when you're gonna have to sprint
the hardest he's like let me see your
data room i was like oh yeah we're
working on it he's like wrong answer
bucko like you know
that's what you shouldn't be at lunch
with me you should be turning your
company into a buy button you need
everything so organized so precise uh
ready for them answer all of their
questions dude did i show you my data
room
you did yeah i had a fire data room me
and this woman named edie this woman
named edie who works with me edie's
probably i think she's in her 60s and
when i hired her she was great but she
didn't like know how to use technology
really and i would it would be like me
and her on the phone with hubspot and
hubspot would have like five
representatives then they would have
like six lawyers who were probably two
grand an hour a piece then they would
have like six accountants and so like
this meeting cost them fifty thousand
dollars it would be edie and i and they
would be asking us questions about
different documents and like okay we'll
get it for you and i remember them like
having a list and he didn't know how to
take a screenshot on a computer and i
just hear her constantly with her phone
and everyone saw she would bring it up
and their phone just taken taking
pictures of the screen
and i just and i would enter the
messenger edie put your photo on silent
i know what you're doing and she was
just taking pictures and we would you
know we talked about fierce nerds edie
is like a fierce grandmother like i
would go to your office and you'd be
like oh how's you know how's your
daughter like she knows her name she's
like remember my daughter's name like
show me pictures she was like so kind
and cuddly she said she'd be like you
submitted your invoice wrong [__]
keep this [__] organized we're running a
tight ship around here and i was like
yeah wow this is how did you find this
woman because i was like she's like the
polar opposite of you but she was so
needed for what you guys had as yours
she was so needed i i've always been
really good at finding those people
because she was she worked in banking
for a long time actually and she was
like really successful banking a person
and she comes off as this like really
nice naive woman it's like not even a
little bit she's like pretty sh not
sharky but like she's she'll get you
because she worked in banking in japan
where she was like helping companies go
public i think at morgan stanley so it's
like she's like a shark
no more
yeah and then she like raised her
daughter she had a daughter and decided
not to work and raised her and she came
to me and she was like uh i don't really
need the money but i want a job to prove
to my young daughter who just graduated
college that uh i'm a badass and that
women could be badasses and i was like
oh yeah cool you're hired id like i love
that and uh she ended up being amazing
and i remember her i'm during the due
diligence process i had a teacher how to
use
uh
dropbox and i had a teacher like some
like pretty like basic computer stuff
like how to like copy and paste and then
she like bought a course on udemy and
stayed up all night and mastered it and
she's like all right i know how to do it
now but like if i didn't show her how to
do something i would see her taking a
screenshot like she would have her phone
just up and here click and i'm like
they could see this anyway sorry go
ahead
she's amazing i don't know what she's
doing now but like
i did i need to hire her she's still
working with you guys yeah she's still
doing that amazing i would have thought
like you know normally in like these
acquisitions they don't like bring on
the finance team or whatever but that's
that's amazing i would never let her go
she's she's so good she's the most
impressive honestly i i like you but she
was the most impressive person at the
hustle
she was wonderful man people know you
they know trolling that stuff she was
the most impersonal impressive person
there yeah she was wonderful
i don't even know what we're talking
about this one oh dear doula
here's the here's the i don't know if
it's a business idea but i hear i know
that if you're gonna do a transaction
you need somebody like this which is
every time i've done one of these things
i need this person and here's what they
teach me how to do they teach me how to
use the lawyers they teach me how to use
the accountants they teach me how to do
the negotiation because they've been
through hundreds of these so they know
what to expect so they can emotionally
coach you when you're like yeah ups and
downs they're their therapist
they're your advisor on the business
side of things the negotiation but
that's honestly the least usually that's
pretty obvious about what you should do
there
they're your your speechwriter and your
copywriter as you uh you know prepare to
like you know
write a pitch deck or um you know a
follow-up email or whatever it is and
the most important thing is they teach
you how to use expensive lawyers and
accountants because if you just go to a
lawyer and you say what should i do
you're going to end up with a document
that's basically the constitution and
it's like oh great you lawyered the [__]
out of this but like that wasn't what we
needed in our business case like you
didn't a lawyer if you defer too much to
the lawyer
they're gonna over lawyer things if you
don't if you don't listen to the lawyer
you're gonna have too much liability how
do you find that line that judgment
is the most important thing and judgment
is something you can't really hack
there's no shortcuts to judgment the
closest thing you can get to it is
partner up or borrow somebody else's
judgment one of these deal doulas so
same thing on the fundraising side you
see a term sheet you don't know all
these terms
what do they mean should i agree to this
liquidation preference they oh they have
this you know clawback thing what what
is this should i agree a deal duel is
the one who can kind of teach you how to
do that or i love that you know my tax
person's suggesting this and they're
gonna say
don't do that it's gonna over yes that
saves you in taxes but it's going to add
deal risk over here because it's going
to introduce delays and complexity that
you don't want to have that's a really
good thing that's been really good
to me i'm like i don't think there's a
business because normally these are
successful business people that's the
only person you get to do this and they
don't want money for this they're just
doing it because they want to help you
typically
maybe somebody could make a business out
of this but even if they don't my advice
to any founder out there is if you're
going through either a fundraising or an
m a process
make sure you have your deal duels to
keep you sane and keep you smart about
how you're going to go through the
process dude there are so many things
that i didn't even know like i didn't
even know to ask for example when people
talk to me about selling their companies
i'll be like well
you know you really want to optimize for
uh
time to close so you want to like close
as quickly as possible because in my
head i was like why does it matter they
gave you a thing i'm like well just [__]
happens for example brian halligan the
ceo of hubspot got into a near-death
accident five days after the deal closed
i'm like if that happened at any other
point or if the economy change like just
[__] happens or like the person leading
the deal quits like stuff changes all
the time and another thing that i didn't
even notice look for is like i would get
these offers from these pe firms from
small businesses from and then hubspot
has a board a board of directors they're
a huge company and they're like well we
we present the loi before we gave it to
you to our board of directors and i was
like this isn't going to go through yada
yada well once the board approves it the
likelihood that it's going to get done
is quite high because the employees have
to look good to the board and they
already like you know they can't whereas
you have another guy who's just like a
smaller business and it's just the
founder leading the deal it's like oh he
you don't give a [__] he'll bail at any
point like he just he's like
you know it's their money they're
you know what i'm saying like the
dynamics are different and so there's
all these things that i didn't quite
understand that now i know
that you really it's hard to learn
unless you've been there because you
don't even know what to ask
with our last deal one of we took the lo
we took the second highest offer like uh
we turned on the top offer
and we took the second offer and why was
that well there was like a bunch of
intangible reasons maybe we preferred
one over the other but it was like you
know i personally
i personally left
i don't know
million and a half to two million
dollars total on the table
uh just me on
taking the second deal over the first
deal which is like that was a lot of
money to me that wasn't small like that
was that was meaningful um
and the reason i did it one of one of
the reasons there was a few the one was
you know our team they we wanted our
team to to our whole team to go with the
deal then and that was only gonna happen
with a second that's probably the
biggest reason but there was some small
reason like commute and stuff like that
then the but the other one was
likelihood to close uh yeah they had
told me they go look
yes we've been a pain in the ass in
negotiation like we're sticklers about
this stuff like we
we don't move super fast but the good
news is that means we've thought it
through and we've got our approvals
already once we sign this thing we will
close and we will close on time and he's
like that's the good news the bad news
is leading up to it we're not the
quickest fastest deal makers who are
going to promise you everything it's
like we're only going to promise you
what we can deliver that's the idea
that's the that's the ideal setup by the
way and i didn't really know how to
value it at the time like he was
pitching it to me as a value and i was
like yeah whatever the other guys are
offering more like what do i care
but in retrospect that actually was
quite an important thing because it's
very important a hundred percent of the
second best deal is better than no deal
from the from the best offer right or
somebody who's gonna re try to retrade
the deal in the last minute like that's
one of the worst signs you can have is
somebody who comes back and
in the 11th hour trying to retrade the
deal and they told us these guys were
like we're not going to retrade the deal
we are going to close and so that's the
good news the bad news is
it takes us longer to get to the term
sheet and we're not necessarily going to
be the top offer we're going to offer
you the best we can
and now i've learned that that's
actually quite important um
in this process but as a first time
first time going through it i didn't
know how to wait that you also gave me
some good advice which was you were like
tell them everything tell them up front
all the reasons that they shouldn't buy
you all the skeletons in the closet drag
them out once okay not the very first
meeting but like once they're interested
and it's getting to where like hey we're
gonna make an offer
um or we're making an offer say
before we do that
i'm going to literally brainstorm and
try to figure out every reason why i
think you maybe shouldn't do this deal
and um you know hey we don't have our
ducks in a row on this
this is an unknown this is like a
contract dispute we're in but whatever
they may be right you you have to drag
those out and basically let somebody run
away then because it is far less painful
and less wasteful to let them run away
then they're going to find it out
no deal closes without the finance so
they're going to find out no matter what
your instinct is oh don't tell them
that's that's always the first time
entrepreneurs instinct it was my
instinct the first time and then i
somebody gave me this advice you gave it
to me also which was no no don't do that
um just tell them what's great what's
bad about your business
you're going to get in bed together they
need to know both sides of it and if you
lie you're getting sued anyway like
you're you're on yeah
you're on the phone you definitely can't
lie you definitely can't lie that's
obvious but you can't even just hope
they don't see it or don't find it
because they're going to see it or find
it and you can and then they're going to
say and then they'll say uh what the
future is
yeah what else are you telling me
and so it was actually a mega trust
builder to do that um you know when we
sold the first company so those are some
of the things that you kind of only
learned through these deals you don't
you don't learn that
except through either experience or
talking with people who are experienced
so anyways that's my rant on deal duel
it's a i think a very underrated thing
we went we've covered it all we've this
has been a this has been a roller
coaster dude there was a comment on
youtube about a guy unsubscribing he
goes ah i'm unsubscribing last few
episodes haven't been great
i replied i said good
yeah you said good some other guy was
like man what are you talking about
these guys are trying to i said
over my dead body i am now
i now work for you
you know
big booty three five seven on youtube
i now work for you i dude one guy
motivated beyond belief to come with a
fire every time
one guy wrote these guys are great comma
overall and i was like oh that's a good
day
you got me
that's that's great that's an amazing
one the uh it's remember petty court
it's petty court and code is in session
uh that's how i feel when i read the
youtube comments
yeah
that that was a good one the comments
are actually quite good
you had such a funny um
such a funny joke in a group chat where
it was the the no offense thing
and then the uh yeah
with all due respect
[Laughter]
you're an ugly dude with all due respect
it's like when people start sentences
saying i'm not racist but uh
it's like oh okay
and the other thing that i hate
people
yeah the other thing i hate what people
say is well at least he's honest i'm
like what but his honest opinion sucks i
don't care if he's honest like i don't
know he's he's a straight shooter like
you shooting [__] though yeah yeah
like you straight shooter yeah but what
you say is stupid and i just you know
what i mean it's like dumb i hate it i
i've always hated that excuse
oh man good time all right
[Music]
you